breaking exclusive news about Star Trek
Legacy we know what the plan is we know
when it's going to be and we know how
power Mount are paying for it welcome to
sidere your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel now enen thank you number one so
very welcome Captain helmet goes without
saying to ignore everything he just said
I usually
do all right this is a Shakedown okay so
this news came in literally overnight
from one of my sources over at Amazon
now I do have a really good source um
over at Paramount as well and they were
also able to confirm this so I am not
putting this in the rumor category
people we are putting this in there this
is what is happening category and what
is happening well as I've told you
repeatedly Paramount have always planned
to do the Legacy series it was not if
but when the problem they don't
necessarily want to pay for it or at
least not all of it they were looking
for a partner that partner was always
going to be Amazon and I can now confirm
that that deal has actually been signed
that there is a deal between Amazon and
Paramount to produce Star Trek Legacy
but there's even more to it than we were
expecting we'll come back to that in a
second so first of all let's talk about
Legacy how is this actually going to
work where are we going to be able to
see it well the deal is between as I say
Amazon Prime and Paramount the show will
Air towards the end of next year and
this will actually be a Prelude to the
peard movie now that actually is really
interesting because what we heard
originally was that the TV series were
going to follow the movie so events of
the peard movie would lead into Star
Trek Legacy it now seems that the
opposite is true and actually the first
season of Star Trek Legacy will show and
the peard TNG movie will follow now I
think that's really interesting and
really exciting because it basically
means The Bard tngg movie really is
going to be a big event so Star Trek
Legacy on our screens by the end of this
year where will we be able to see it so
I'm being told this is going to be very
similar to the um peard deal where we
will see it on Paramount plus um on sa
Thursday but that will only be in the
United States it will then air into
internationally on Prime and Paramount
plus then the next day so this is a
three-day basically delivery Paramount
Plus on the Thursday Prime on the Friday
everywhere else in the world on
Paramount that they deliver Paramount on
the Saturday this is how that will work
and for that Prime will actually pay
Paramount up to 30% of the production
costs for the show now that is a decent
chunk of money for the deal they're
getting why have Paramount done this
well as we've told you repeatedly it's
not if but when with this series it was
always going to happen but paramounts
desperately need to cut costs bosses
over at parmount have decided that costs
need to drop by at least 30% across all
of the TV shows so secret hideout need
to make those savings the only way they
can do it is by either cutting the cost
of the television show dramatically or
by bringing in other partners that will
foot at least part of the bill that is
what's going to be happening with most
of Star Trek moving forward and again
will lead into another reason why actual
secret hideout was going to be changing
to Star Trek Studios at some point in
the next 12
months if you're enjoying the video
don't forget to like subscribe hit that
thumbs up leave a comment and all those
things but also go and check us out on
patreon.com cidre most of our videos do
premere their first this video actually
premiered nearly 10 hours before it did
on YouTube and a lot of our videos
actually Premier 24 hours before they do
on YouTube so go over check check that
out so why do I mention the peard movie
and how this is also part of that deal
so I have to say straight off the bat I
don't know if this is going to include
section 31 but I suspect it might or any
of the other TV movies that secret hi
and Paramount of planning but again I
suspect it might but it seems for peard
there is a deal in place now that the
peard movie that will again follow
Legacy will actually a premiere on Prime
first behind a payall so actually be
something we have to initially rent if
we want to see it it will then after a
few weeks premere on Paramount plus so
when this movie comes out first of all
it'll be on Prime but you'll have to pay
maybe like 5.99 or whatever to watch it
and then it'll move over to Paramount
plus where we'll all be able to see as
part of our Paramount Plus subscription
so when will this be announced when will
filming be happening and obviously the
big question will Terry metalis be
involved well first of all I'm I'm being
told this is actually going to be
announced in the summer this agreement
between prime and Paramount is just the
first step they have basically now been
able to figure out the how and they will
start building towards the when the idea
though currently is that this will film
um back toback with the movie and that
filming will start roughly um the middle
to late summer the announcement will be
sometime in early summer so we will get
the announcement and that should then
follow on three or four months later
when filming starts as I say the idea
being that the series will hit our
screens by the end of late 2025 and the
movie will follow a couple of months
after that and I really do think the
peard movie I think is actually going to
be a TNG movie if I'm honest and
obviously a legacy crossover is really
going to be touted by Paramount as a big
Star Trek event it's really going to be
the big thing in early
2026 I think they're going to actually
throw everything at this project finally
Terry mat is he going to be involved
well I actually dropped this news oh God
six months ago or so exclusively that
powermount still consider teralis he to
be the preferred um showrunner producer
potentially even writing um significant
portion of the series and maybe even
getting involved in the movie but he
does have a very busy schedule at the
moment he's currently writing and
producing Witch Mountain for Disney he's
also involved in another project the
last American vampire he's also written
several other projects trying to get
going so he's very busy at the moment
but Paramount do have a backup plan
somebody else from Secret hideous will
show run in co-partnership with Jonathan
Franks who will take a much more leading
role with the Legacy and potentially the
um Picard movie as well he would be
directing and he would be far more
involved in a production side as well it
to be honest it's the next logical step
for Jonathan Frank with Star Trek who
he's been getting more and more involved
with secret hideouts projects obviously
ly very very involved in strange new
worlds as well and actually getting more
involved in the management Show run
inside of it is really just the next
logical step for him um I think Jonathan
Frank though may not appear in the movie
in the series much I think it's far more
likely that the reer character will be a
little bit more in the background if he
appears in either at all so just to
recap then this deal between prime and
Paramount has been agreed it will be
announced at some point in the next four
or five months months I suspect at one
of the early big conventions maybe even
San Diego Comic Con even though that's
June so I think that might be a bit
later I think it might be on something a
bit sooner than that so um you guys get
into the comments and tell me when you
think this will be announced but this is
the first step the business decision
it's the how now they will start
figuring out the when and once all those
things are lined up I'm certain this
will be announced really
quickly this will be on our screens by
late 2025 and the movie will follow in
early 2026
that is what is agreed right now now
obviously things can go horribly wrong
and I suspect actually what happens to
Paramount in the next 12 months could
massively affect all of these deals at
the end of the day Paramount are still
behaving as if they're going to exist in
12 months but new owners might change
this from top to bottom let's see what
happens from a business point of view
with Paramount in the next 12 months and
see if Star Trek gets affected I'm
hoping not though because this does seem
to be part of a bigger Five-Year Plan
for Star Trek and obviously I think this
TNG movie stroke Legacy movie could
actually be really really big for
Paramount and I'm hoping the new owners
will consider that when they're making
any decisions but guys get into the
comments tell me what you think about
this exclusive breaking news is it
something you're excited by is it going
to take too long do we want to ask
screen sooner but you know these things
do take a while and is this something
you expected or is this a complete
surprise get into the comments and tell
me exactly what you think if you are new
to the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos also you can go to
patreon.com citrek where this video did
Premiere first and actually a lot of our
videos do premere at least 24 hours
before they do on YouTube over on the
patreon channel so please go and check
it out also you go to c.c. UK which is
our dedicated website and we do stories
based on most of our videos so please go
and check that out too as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
bosses over at parmount have decided
that all of the TV shows
[Music]
cost